[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante las últimas décadas la
tecnología ha transformado nuestro mundo
de forma radical y en todos los sentidos
gracias a los avances tecnológicos poco
tiene que ver el estilo de vida que
llevaron nuestros padres ni hablemos ya
de nuestros abuelos con respecto al que
nosotros disfrutamos hoy en día cosas
como poder monitorizar el pulso en
tiempo real general gráficos automáticos
de tu actividad cardiaca a través del
móvil controlar hasta el último
parámetro de tu actividad física estar
siempre conectado con tus amigos y tu
familia o el hecho de poder tener
reuniones de empresa desde tu
apartamento de la playa por
videoconferencia hubieran sonado como
una auténtica locura hasta hace tan solo
unos pocos años ahora bien como todo
este mundo y como siempre os decimos en
visual político no todos son luces el
avance tecnológico también reído consigo
algunas sombras y por supuesto podemos
encontrar dobles varas de medir en
cuanto a cómo los estados y algunas
multinacionales utilizan la tecnología
para fines digamos igual no tan buenos
especialmente cuando hablamos de
tecnologías que permiten monitorizar y
seguir la actividad de las personas
el arranque del 2020 ha sido una buena
muestra del potencial que tienen las
nuevas tecnologías para hacer frente por
ejemplo a crisis sanitarias como la que
se ha producido con el sars coronavirus
2 por ejemplo actualmente en muchos
países se están empleando aplicaciones
para rastrear y geolocalizar a los
ciudadanos que hayan podido estar en
contacto con personas contagiadas
[Música]
por voz o localización aplicaciones
israelíes pueden determinar tu riesgo
frente a corona virus
otro buen ejemplo es el de corea del sur
donde uno de los grandes éxitos en la
prevención de contagios y la detección
temprana de casos de sars coronavirus 2
ha sido precisamente el uso intensivo de
medios tecnológicos incluso hasta
límites controvertidos
corea del sur impone pulseras
electrónicas para los que desafían las
órdenes de cuarentena es algo que os
contamos con todo lujo de detalles en un
vídeo que hicimos sobre como corea del
sur se ha enfrentado el coronavirus os
dejo el link en la descripción por si
aún no habéis visto
ahora bien por supuesto este uso de la
tecnología no siempre sale tan bien
como os podéis imaginar este tipo de
aplicaciones y sistemas de seguimiento a
veces tienen fallos desperdiciados días
encerrado en mi habitación gracias a la
desastrosa aplicación del ministerio de
salud sin embargo más allá de este tipo
de percances anecdóticos acechan otros
peligros mucho pero que mucho más
importantes
amigos el mayor problema que presentan
estas nuevas tecnologías tiene que ver
sobre todo con la nueva capacidad que
tienen los estados para controlar a las
personas
y si vale puede que a los que nos estáis
viendo desde sólidas democracias desde
países donde las libertades esenciales
están garantizadas todo esto no sea algo
que hoy por hoy al menos hoy por hoy os
dé tanto miedo
pero pensar lo diferente que puede ser
la situación en países dirigidos por
dictadores o por gobiernos con pocos
escrúpulos
en esos casos estas nuevas capacidades
tecnológicas pueden convertirse en
auténticas armas de control social
pensado por ejemplo en el caso de china
con la excusa de coronavirus el gobierno
ha extendido y generalizado sistema de
geolocalización muy intrusivos en la
vida privada de las personas incluso han
ido más allá del simple rastreo
han aprovechado esta crisis para
potenciar códigos sociales que ya
existían desde hace algunos años como
por ejemplo el nuevo código de salud
hablamos de códigos que te califican en
función de ciertos parámetros y
determinan si puede o no hacer ciertas
cosas
[Música]
pero que supone realmente todo esto
dónde está exactamente el peligro son
medidas temporales o se convertirán en
permanentes incluso una vez que la
crisis de coronavirus haya sido superada
que puede hacer el gobierno chino con
estas nuevas tecnologías de
identificación y geolocalización
amigos para conocer más sobre todo este
asunto en este vídeo os vamos a contar
como la tecnología está cambiando
también la forma en que los estados los
gobiernos vigilan nuestras vidas de esta
forma trataremos de aproximarnos a los
riesgos que pueden plantearse
[Música]
y no no creáis que os vamos a hablar
solo de china es más apuesto aquí en
cosas que vais a escuchar en este vídeo
que os van a resultar sorprendentes
atentos
[Música]
china de dictadura a estado policial
estoy seguro de que muchos habéis
escuchado que china tiene una de las
tecnologías más avanzadas del mundo en
vigilancia social sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta su aplicación a escala masiva
algo que les ha permitido durante la
pandemia del coronavirus establecer unos
sistemas de vigilancia restricción y
prohibiciones como nunca antes se habían
visto fijaos
hablamos por ejemplo del famoso código
de salud un semáforo de colores por el
que se clasifica a la gente en función
de si han tenido coronavirus algún
impacto con gente que lo tuvo o si
visitaron zonas de alto riesgo este
sistema fue desarrollado inicialmente
por el gobierno local de hunt show pero
se ha extendido por todo el país
actualmente está instalado en widget y
el whatsapp chino y en alipay la
plataforma de pago de alí babá
pues bien como widget y way sin su
versión china tienen mil 160 millones de
usuarios y alipay unos 900 millones
podemos decir que prácticamente todos
los chinos tienen al menos una de estas
dos apps aplicaciones que utilizan en su
día a día pues bien muchas funciones han
sido restringidas o condicionadas al
código de salud
ahora bien cómo funciona exactamente
este semáforo que marca y clasifica a
los ciudadanos
[Música]
pues bien digamos que hay varias maneras
por un lado si las autoridades
sanitarias determinan que tienes o más
tenido recientemente coronavirus o bien
que has estado en contacto con algún
infectado
entonces se le otorga el color rojo
ah
y luego si este no es el caso los
usuarios también tienen que hacer un
cuestionario lo que sumado a otros datos
como la geolocalización a través de los
móviles determinan tus posibilidades de
haber estado expuesto o al menos haber
estado cerca del vídeo
de ese modo se te puede calificar como
amarillo o como verde siendo el verde el
color que te da libertad casi absoluta
dentro de las restricciones actuales
y ojo no penséis ni por un momento que
esto es algo que se utiliza poco en
china se están empleando de estos
códigos de salud para casi todo para
entrar en el metro o para ir a comprar
para ir a un restaurante y una cafetería
hasta para autorizar pagos de billetes
de avión o de tren
en definitiva que la vida y la libertad
de mucha gente puede estar girando ahora
en torno al color que tengan asignado
[Música]
si puede que esto te parezca una
historia sacada de black mirror pero lo
que os estamos contando es lo que ya
está funcionando nada de ciencia ficción
ahora bien seguramente muchos estáis
pensando pero enrique que tiene todo
esto de malo tenía cabo está siendo algo
bueno para luchar contra el coronavirus
no es gracias a todo esto que china está
logrando controlar la pandemia
[Aplausos]
pues sí pero el problema amigos es el
uso indiscriminado que un gobierno puede
hacer de todas estas herramientas
de hecho el uso de este tipo de
tecnologías en china para controlar o
restringir la libertad no es algo que
haya surgido ni mucho menos a raíz de la
crisis el coronavirus y por supuesto
como todos sabemos china no es
precisamente un icónico país donde los
derechos humanos y las libertades
civiles sean lo primero más bien todo lo
contrario
de hecho lo que parece es que ahora el
coronavirus puede actuar ni más ni menos
que como la excusa perfecta para
popularizar y perpetuar medidas tan
controvertidas o delicadas como esta
fijaos china está instalando cámaras de
vigilancia frente a las puertas de las
viviendas y a veces incluso dentro tras
un viaje al sur de china el expatriado
irlandés de 34 años y su familia
comenzaron sus dos semanas de cuarentena
domiciliaria una medida obligatoria
impuesta por el gobierno de pekín para
detener la expansión del coronavirus
hijo que abrió la puerta de su casa
cuando la cámara estaba siendo instalada
sin previo aviso tener una cámara frente
a tu puerta es una increíble erosión de
la privacidad no sé cuánto de esto es
legal cámaras incluso las puertas de
casa sorprendidos pues no deberíais
y las cosas que se están poniendo en
práctica durante esta crisis sanitaria
venían ya ensayándose desde hace muchos
años
si no tiene ciudades en las que resulta
prácticamente imposible escapar de los
ojos de las autoridades a nivel nacional
hay unos 200 millones de cámaras de
vigilancia y algunas ciudades se han
convertido literalmente en un gran
hermano por ejemplo en la ciudad de
chongching la ciudad más vigilada del
planeta se cerró 2019 con algo más de 2
millones y medio de cámaras de
vigilancia para 15 35 millones de
habitantes es decir una cámara para cada
59 habitantes
y eso no es todo lo más preocupante
desde el punto de vista de la privacidad
y las libertades son los avances en
técnicas de reconocimiento facial con
fines de vigilancia una materia en la
que china es el líder indiscutible a
nivel mundial
[Música]
y fijaos por ejemplo en sense o una
ciudad industrial situada en la zona
central del país aquí las autoridades
han combinado de forma masiva la
videovigilancia con el rastreo de las
telecomunicaciones para crear uno de los
sistemas de detección facial más
avanzados y precisos del mundo pero y
como funciona pues bien la policía tiene
instaladas junto a muchas de las cámaras
de vigilancia unas cajas blancas que son
rastreadores de antenas de móvil de ese
modo las imágenes captadas por las
cámaras pueden cotejar las caras de la
gente y con sus teléfonos móviles y su
geoposicionamiento de tal forma que el
sistema pueda determinar si realmente la
persona detectada por la cámara es la
que está en ese lugar ahora bien la
pregunta es para qué quiere el régimen
chino toda esta tecnología pues bien una
pista de lo que les espera a los chinos
en un futuro próximo la podemos
encontrar en la ciudad costera de rosell
cada uno de los 670 mil habitantes de la
ciudad de rawson reciben de entrada mil
puntos como ciudadanos en función de
cómo se porten y de lo que hagan pueden
perder o ganar puntos por ejemplo que te
peleas con tu vecino cinco puntos menos
y no haces lo que hay que hacer cuando
sacas al perro 10 puntos menos que dona
sangre pues cinco puntos más por
supuesto ya te puedes ir olvidando de
manifestarse en contra de las
autoridades o hacer cualquier comentario
negativo sobre la situación política
económica o social del país porque
entonces las cosas se podrían poner muy
pero que muy complicadas
[Música]
y es que veréis con este sistema a las
autoridades han fijado una escala de
acciones y actividades de la vida
cotidiana que se pueden o no pueden
acometer en función del nivel de puntos
que tengas por ejemplo si pierdes un
determinado nivel de puntos entonces tus
libertades más básicas como por ejemplo
la movilidad comienzan a restringirse y
ojo porque hablamos de una escala que
puede impedirte acceder a un préstamo
bancario o reservas incluso de un
billete de tren
[Aplausos]
qué os parece de locos verdad pues de
momento son planes pilotos pero el
riesgo de que se generalicen parece cada
vez mayor
y ojo porque si esto os parece ya algo
increíble fuera de china en países que
podemos considerar libres y el uso de
las tecnologías de vigilancia para la
monitorización social no es algo tan
raro ni tan infrecuente como podríamos
llegar a pensar atentos
[Música]
vigilar un vicio universal lo primero de
todo te hago una pregunta crees que está
justificado mermar la privacidad de la
gente en los espacios públicos a cambio
de una mayor seguridad si sé que es un
tema complejo y lo cierto es que no creo
que haya una respuesta clara para todo
esto hay personas que priorizan la
privacidad y la libertad por encima de
todo y otras que digamos prefieren la
seguridad
sin embargo alguna de las cosas que
estamos viendo hoy en día incluso fuera
de china ojo nos hacen plantearnos y
quizás el camino que se ha puesto en
marcha en algunos países no sea digamos
el más adecuado
[Música]
hay varios países considerados libres y
democráticos como por ejemplo eeuu o
especialmente el reino unido que también
están intentando desarrollar sistemas de
detección facial al estilo chino
claro que hoy por hoy las limitaciones
de la tecnología por fortuna o por
desgracia según quien lo mire son
todavía muy importantes
[Música]
por ejemplo una prueba realizada por la
policía de gales del sur en reino unido-
con un sistema de detección facial
mediante cámaras llamado neo face
determinó que durante las 55 horas en
funcionamiento de las 2900 posibles
coincidencias sólo 145 fueron positivos
reales es decir fueron reconocimientos
faciales positivos de la persona
correcta
[Música]
pero es evidente que esta brecha
tecnológica puede cerrarse muy pero que
muy rápidamente la policía de londres se
está llevando a la vigilancia un nuevo
nivel el departamento de policía de
londres ha dicho que empezarán a usar
reconocimiento facial para detectar a
sospechosos criminales con videocámaras
mientras caminan por la calle adoptando
un nivel de vigilancia que se extraño
fuera de china sí sí tal cual como lo
escucháis
para lograrlo la capital británica
quiere hacer uso de sus más de 600
27.000 cámaras de vigilancia repartidas
por toda la ciudad la infraestructura de
este tipo más grande de todo el
continente europeo hablamos de más de 68
cámaras por cada 1000 londinenses
evidentemente el resultado que puede
tener el uso de estos sistemas no será
el mismo en un país como el reino unido-
que en la autocrática china pero amigos
la privacidad y la privacidad parece
cada vez más coordenada y eso nos obliga
a hacernos algunas preguntas está
justificado expandir a todos los
rincones de nuestra vida la
videovigilancia en nombre de la
seguridad debemos aceptar que se ceda a
los gobiernos datos de localización de
nuestros móviles para eventualmente
resolver un crimen que es más importante
para vosotros la seguridad o la
privacidad es posible acaso alcanzar un
punto medio o queréis que siempre va a
existir una tendencia a vigilar más más
y más en fin en un próximo vídeo veremos
más sobre algunos planes de este tipo
puestos en marcha por algunos de los
gobiernos más poderosos del mundo pero
de momento de momento nos encantaría
conocer vuestra opinión así que ya
sabéis como siempre os decimos dejadnos
vuestros comentarios aquí abajo y si os
ha gustado este vídeo no olvidéis darle
a like suscribiros abisal político una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]